le maillot de diego maradona mis aux
enchères il ya quinze jours on en avait
parlé ici même eh bien il a trouvé un
acquéreur pour combien une somme
astronomique 8,8 millions d'euros un
romain bio ou est ce que je fais ce que
neuf c'est ça et c'est un record pour
une pièce de collection sportive maillot
qui auraient été portées par maradona
lors du match de légende face à
l'angleterre pendant la coupe du monde
86 savez c'est la fameuse main de dieu
doit vous avouer quelque chose hier j'ai
vu passer cette histoire et j'ai cru que
c'était le maillot de madonna est en
fait je suis pas j'avais mal lu chiu
alors je suis aussi ça fait très cher
pour un maillot de madonna quand même
oui en fait il faut juste que je change
de lunettes oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu peux me dessiner me sculpté en pâte à
modeler tu peux et tout n'allait pas à
l'école et la salle l'étoile classé le
colorier me tatouer on entendra parler
ce
qu'on disait à temps je sais moi qui
parle ça va quoi hockey
une prétention sans nommer la dernière
je te sens triste à dire mais vous
couper la parole mme mazel un don mais
vous
si vous parlez pas de ce verdict je vous
assure yvon ils vont pas laisser parler
tout seul je vous lis ici il faut être
mal élevés je vous le dis ah bah moi je
suis très mal élevé moise interrompt les
genres dont une très très mal élevé bon
nombre
intègre en france nous défendons depuis
la plupart étaient des données de
secondes mais c'est un son parfaitement
prête une arène
cela dit au niveau
beauté quand il part s'il vous plaît
donc brisement tu me laisses fait
tourner ses finitions vous me dites
quand ça commence démission on sait
comment s'est investi complètement
indiffusables votre truc basse et touche
pas à mon poste
est ce que je peux faire une déclaration
bien sûr c'est cela
la déclaration de jean d'amour
[Applaudissements]
c'est terriblement
ah les trois erreurs à ne pas connaître
lors d'un premier rendez vous à ne pas
commettre lors d'un premier rendez vous
c'est l'application l'iran construit en
fond de vallée comme
l'application rencontre happen qui a
sondé ses utilisateurs sur les trois
faux pas à éviter lors d'un premier jet
je vois que laurent est très attentif
alors
je suis prêt à ne pas commettre numéro
un selon les sondés l'absence de sujets
de conversation à 'la il faut avoir des
choses à dire sepsi ça existe encore
fait je te prie des coquillages des
coupes sombres
sur la plage et 3h30 pour tout prendre
sa
deuxième point rédhibitoire une trop
grande différence physique par rapport
au foot à la non maîtrise et laulala la
photo de thé défendre plaquette de
vie damman et enfin troisième point très
important ne pas trop parler de son
gabarit il serrait ces cinq-là fixa
c'est un classique ne faut pas à éviter
absolument
je vous rappelle qu'elle est actrice ou
déjà comme ça vous allez remarquer cette
image regardez la bien regarder des
riens qui vous frappent la façon d'un
tablier oui à la costume d'homme pour
pour ne pas être trop sexy trop féminine
sur dakar elle est plutôt jolie très bas
à costumes donne avec une chemise
d'homme qu'elle a dans l affaire mais le
coach c'est pas très élégant non plus
avec le japon à présent avec cette
tradition quelque peu étonnante qui peut
nous paraître barbare avec cette
compétition de leur de vv
regardez des enfants s'affrontent sur un
ring à coups de larmes et de cris le
premier qui me semblerait bruyamment
remporte le concours il fait pleurer
exprès absolument attendez vous allez
comprendre pourquoi environ 60 db à à
participer à cet événement des larmes
qui serait signe au japon de bonne santé
au revoir si tu rigoles sans bruit
des sûr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]